okay well you said it I didn't know what
it really was until 2018. what is it
like what is you you said what is it I I
have some ideas but I can't fully
understand uh what it truly is other
than when I go to the store value topic
I'm like that seems the most sense to me
and the fact that it can be held offline
and and and remain anonymous and all of
those things but the store value kind of
gets defeated most of the time because
either a it's volatile or B or as a
medium of exchange the other argument is
like if I think it's going up why would
I ever pay someone in Bitcoin so from
your perspective I'm just a dumb real
estate guy from Texas
what is bitcoin
yeah don't worry I'm dumb too
the more the more the following we get
online the Dumber we become to everybody
else that in that kind of the the way it
works Elon Musk Elon Musk is apparently
like the dumbest person in the world now
it's so true there's an inverse
correlation the promise of Bitcoin from
the white paper is you know electronic
peer-to-peer cash so just think money on
the internet uh not backed by a central
bank so kind of No One controls it if
you will we can go down that path and
kind of talk about like hey here's what
it's supposed to be I think the easier
way to kind of understand it is just
like the way that I view Bitcoin is that
nobody will argue the world is going to
get less automated like the world is
going to be more automated in the future
and most people agree with that and so
when you look at every single thing in
your life software has slowly but surely
eaten into it right software eating the
world
to me Bitcoin is simply an automated
Central Bank so it is a monetary
institution that happens to be codified
via software code that has stated this
is what our monetary policy is going to
be regardless of what happens in the
world we are not going to change
and we have a limited Supply so finite
limited Supply with a programmatic
monetary policy and the reason why that
becomes interesting to me is that it's
pretty much 180 degrees opposite of
every other currency in the world every
other currency says we have humans that
are going to make variable decisions
based on what's happening in the world
and there's an unlimited Supply
and so if you know you know anything
about tech investing basically you have
to do something different than everyone
else and you have to be right so like
Bitcoin just from a structural
standpoint checks the box of it is
definitely doing something different
than everybody else where the debate
comes in is is it right and so when I
started to look at it the thing that I
kept saying to myself was just like man
the fact that it doesn't change is going
to be so important in a world that
appears to be accelerating change and I
think 2020 and 2021 was like a perfect
example we had like the shortest
recession in history in March and April
then we had trillions of dollars printed
fiscal policy it was like money falling
out of the sky uh we're bailing out
Industries we're like doing all these
different things
and at the same time Bitcoin is going
through that exact same world it's just
doing exactly what it's programmed to do
and so I realized I was like oh wait a
second
monetary policies in the Fiat world are
reactionary they react to what's
happening and that is really put on a
pedestal as a positive
Bitcoin says no we're not going to react
to the world we simply are going to
continue to do what we say we're going
to do and so remain kind of disciplined
or programmatic
now when you look at it from managing an
economy standpoint reacting to what's
happening is viewed as a positive but
what it does is it makes it very hard on
the individual level to plan your life
if you were at the beginning of 2020
thinking that you know inflation was
going to be two percent and you were
making investment or financial decisions
on that pretty much by like mid 21 you
were like oh [__] I miscalculated right
like that's only 18 months and then
you're like okay interest rates are zero
so you make some other financial
decisions and then like pretty much a
year later you're like oh [__] nope
interest rates are flying up right like
things got more expensive and so it's
very hard for you to plan long term if
the cost of capital keeps changing if
the monetary policy changes then and
also fiscal but but mainly monetary
Bitcoin just solves all that it just
says like no we're just going to do what
we say we're going to do
now what that leads to is the world
trying to figure out what the hell is
this thing Worth right and to your
comment about like the volatility
the volatility of Bitcoin is
non-existent
right Bitcoin is not volatile it's The
Exchange price that's volatile and so
the same thing is like the dollar isn't
necessarily volatile right at one dollar
is one dollar it's what can the one
dollar buy you that is volatile The
Exchange price now they're both volatile
to a degree bitcoin's obviously more
volatile from a percentage standpoint
um but you know over the last two years
the dollars lost 20 of its purchasing
power Bitcoins up right so so it's like
you know pick your uh favorite timeline
twist the data however you want it's
like they're both moving
um and uh and you can look at it like
that and then the last thing I would say
is like to your point about store value
in my opinion if Bitcoin becomes the
global store of value similar to like
how I would uh uh look at like a real
estate uh type um you know asset class
across the world
that would be a win if it just became a
store of value I think uh while some of
the most hardcore bitcoiners would not
be happy they feel like it failed uh I
think for most people that would be a
win if it then can also become a medium
of exchange and even maybe a unit of
account that's like all icing on the on
the cake to me but just creating a
digital store of value that you control
that you can plan your life around I
think would have immense positive impact
on you know billions of people around
the world
but we still got a lot of work to do
right I mean there's like 100 to 150
million people they estimate I have
Bitcoin to get to billions you're
literally talking about 10x or more
um you know increase in the user base
and so I think where you get a lot of
the the folks in the Bitcoin Community
although they don't like to admit it if
you have a fixed Supply asset and you
think that 10x more people are going to
come in and try to get it the price will
go up and so there's this element of
like Supply demand economics take over
and people are capitalist slash greedy
and so they naturally they want to hold
an asset before everyone else that'll go
up in price right
so is there anything about the the
promise of Bitcoin that's actually
happening like today or is it still like
accumulate what you can because the
promise is coming and you'll be glad
that you have it all once the promise
came or there are people today that
would say like I'm living out my Bitcoin
dream right now
yeah this is a really good question I I
um I recently read a book uh being
mortal by a tool gawandi
um and in it he talks about this idea of
like happiness is expectations minus
reality uh and so like I think to answer
the question of like I'm living out my
Bitcoin dream like what what is the
dream right did you expect it to be a
unit of account by now well like no
you're not happy if you expected it just
to serve as a personal store of value
then you're actually pretty happy right
if you go back and you look even though
Bitcoin uh went all the way up to sixty
nine thousand dollars it's now down like
75 percent still around what's called
sixteen thousand dollars give or take
um that's up a hundred percent it was
like eight thousand dollars uh starting
2020. so like since the pandemic you
know until now it's basically doubled in
price there's a lot of people who are
like damn that's better than my stock
portfolio or my bonds or you know
whatever else in value the question is
just like do you have the stomach to
ride volatility of you know whatever
eight thousand to sixty four thousand
back down to Thirty back up to sixty
nine back down to 16 like that's a lot
of volatility in there
um and so what it does is it actually
incentivizes dollar cost averaging into
what many people including myself
believe is a great asset and then just
hold it for a long time
which if I was not talking about Bitcoin
you would be like oh that's like Warren
Buffett and Charlie Munger right like
just like buy great assets hold them
forever I mean in real estate you guys
do similar things uh the question of
what's a great asset though is where a
lot of the debate